ينضم الينا من زبروجيا مراسل جزيره حسان
مسعود ومن دونيسك مراسله الجزيره كارمن جو
خضار حسان نتابع معك ما الذي سجلته
الساعات الاولى من هذا اليوم من تطورات
على المستوى الميداني والسياسي
نعم
المدن الاوكرانيه في اكثر من اتجاه على
ضربات بالصواريخ والمسيرات الانتحاريه
نبدا من الشمال من منطقه خرجف التي هجمت
بمسيرات انتحاريه ونمر على منطقه دنيتك
ايضا التي كانت قد شهدت خلال الليله
الفائته قصفا عنيفا ايضا بالصواريخ
والمدفعيه ونصل الى هذه المنطقه منطقه
زابولوجيا جنوب شرقي اوكرانيا التي ايضا
تعرضت لهاجمات بمسيارات الانتحاريه تقول
السلطات انها اسقطتها في السماء
ووصولا الى اقصى الجنوب عند البحر الاسود
في منطقه اوديسا وتلك المدينه تعرضت لهجمه
صاروخيه بصواريخ من طراز كالبر اطلقت من
السفن الحربيه الروسيه في البحر الاسود
وادى ذلك الى
قصف طال مبنى سكنيا مجمع تحتوي على عدد من
المساكن وكذلك المتاجر وادى هذا القصف الى
مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص واصابه اكثر من ثلاثه
عشر اخرين هذه الضربات ايضا تاتي بالتوازي
مع ضربه وجهه نحو منطقه كريفو جراد وسط
البلاد
وتقول الاداره العسكريه هناك انه لم يكن
هناك مصابين انما كان هناك اضرار ماديه
كبيره هذه الضربات تاتي لمناطق تقع في عمق
الجبهات هذه الجبهه الممتده من الشرق
وصولا الى اقصى الجنوب
وهذه الجبهه تشهد تطورات على عدد من
الاتجاهات بدايه من باخمت التي تقول
القوات الاوكرانيه انها تحاول التقدم
باتجاهها لاسيما باتجاه الاطراف شمالي
وجنوبي منطقه باخموت فيما ايضا يجري
الحديث عن تطورات على طول جبهه تافريا
المنطقه الجنوبيه الشرقيه لاوكرانيا هناك
تحركات عند المنطقه الواقعه بين
مقاطعتي دنياتك هناك تحاول القوات
الاوكرانيه التقدم يقول المتحدث باسم هيئه
الاركان ان هناك نجاحات وان كانت محدوده
يتحدث عن بضع كيلومترات فقط باتجاه هذه
المحاور وهناك حديث غير رسمي عن ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول التقدم غربي مقاطعه
باتجاه منطقه
وبعض المناطق ايضا المحيطه بها عند
المنطقه الغربيه هذا كله يشير الى ان
محاولات التحرك الاوكرانيه هي باكثر من
اتجاه باتجاه مدن كبرى بدايه نتحدث عن
الشرق عن باخمد كما ذكرنا او في محاوله
للتقدم باتجاه مناطق ومدن كبرى في الساحل
عند ساحل بحر ازوف او عند ساحلي البحر
الاسود محاولات للتقدم باتجاه وهي منطقه
بعيده عن مناطق الجبهه تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه انها تقدمت كيلو متر واحد فقط
باتجاه تلك المدينه ومحاوله التقدم
بالتجاهي منطقه ميل توبل ايضا في مقاطعه
قبلها وايضا في محاوله التوجه غربا غربا
مقاطعه
كل هذه او عفوا كل هذه التطورات تاتي ايضا
بالتزامن مع مخاطر اخرى مازلنا نتحدث عن
تبعات السد وتفجير سد كخوفكا الذي ايضا
ينعكس على محطه النوويه لان محطه تقع
شرقيه المنطقه التي تعرضت
للاستهداف في منطقه خوفكا وهذه المنطقه
كانت تحتوي على خزان للمياه الذي يقع خلف
السد بعد تفجير السد خرجت كميات كبيره من
هذه المياه انخفض منسوب المياه من اكثر من
سته عشره مترا الى 13 مترا وهذا الخزان
الذي كان للمياه كان لتبريد خزانات
ومفاعلات المفاعلات النوويه في محطه
الهويه وخساره هذه المياه يمكن ان يؤثر
على ذلك ولذلك نحن ننتظر زياره لرئيس
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه الى تلك
المحطه طبعا حسان